hey guys
so I talk about abortion every day
often on this app and I find that people have a hard time grasping or like
believing me when I talk about the dangers of the fetal personhood movement
which is conservatives movement to give fetuses constitutional rights
equal to the woman or anyone else walking around
I'm just putting this comments out here
remind you guys that these people exist
they're trying to like
create this alternate reality
and convince people that it's not really a woman growing a fetus with her body
it's not her body it's this completely independent human being that just like
happens to be inside of her
we should talk about the dangers of the fetal personhood movement right
like you will see pregnancy criminalization levels that you've never seen
we're already seeing stories of people being criminalized for their miscarriage
because states are saying
what wasn't actually a miscarriage
we think it was a self induced abortion
consider addicts who get pregnant right
so right now you know
we want we don't want to criminalize addicts who get pregnant
because we want them to go to the doctor
we want them to seek help
obviously they won't do that
because if you're an addict and you get pregnant
you will know that you're not only facing potential negligence charges
but you might even be facing murder charges
which again
they won't seek medical care
so it will have disastrous health outcomes for everyone
involved certainly not hope
the fetus
I don't see where pregnancy criminalization in a fetal personhood world ends
so I mean
you could be doing anything maybe um
you harm your fetus because you were texting and driving
and you got in an accident where um
you had a bad diet like you did anything that harmed the fetus
you're potentially facing jail time now and again
we are already seeing this
please vote blue in the selection